tú me dices christing
y vamos a empezar
hola
hola buenas tardes nos escuchan bien
todos por allá
vamos a ver en el chat
hola hola
perfecto muchas gracias salen
bueno buenas tardes mi nombre es laura
camacho el día de hoy tenemos esta
sesión breve para dar continuidad al
entrenamiento de khan academy durante el
campeonato sabemos que por ahí hay
muchos profesores que ya están
registrados en caná academy que ya
tienen clases con más de 10 alumnos pero
que no no comprendemos todavía
exactamente cómo funciona el campeonato
ni
vaya cuáles son como las reglas que debo
de hacer cuantas actividades debo de
tener o de asignar a la semana entonces
en esta sesión el día de hoy va a ser un
poco más de preguntas y respuestas vale
aquí tenemos la liga para la
presentación del día de hoy por ahí en
el chat
christina se las va a estar compartiendo
para que puedan ustedes entrar
a la liga y darle una revisadita a la
presentación
vale el primer paso bueno el programa de
capacitación ustedes obviamente pueden
acceder a este programa de capacitación
y que se reconozca el tiempo que ustedes
están invirtiendo en prepararse y en
tener más herramientas para utilizar con
sus alumnos lo único que tienen que
hacer es llenar el formulario con el
correo de khan academy para recibir el
reconocimiento por su esfuerzo sale por
otro lado también hay un documento con
información del programa entonces estas
dos ligas las van a poder encontrar en
esta presentación que como les comentaba
yo hace un momentito christine va a
estar compartiendo con ustedes
para que puedan tener acceso a toda esta
información salen
bien pues el campeonato ya empezó empezó
la semana pasada el 10 de septiembre va
a durar 10 semanas termina el 16 de
noviembre entonces es una excelente
oportunidad para que nosotros podamos
participar no importa que ya haya
empezado podemos todavía registrarnos
para para ser parte del campeonato y
para recibir el reconocimiento del
módulo 2
y van ustedes a tener que participar en
el campeonato y tener una clase con más
de 10 alumnos hay muchos de ustedes que
tienen clases muy grandes ya pero que no
están asignando actividades entonces lo
ideal es que nosotros podamos tener una
clase con mínimo mínimo 10 alumnos y
empezar a asignar 3 actividades durante
la semana y que los muchachos las
contesten al 100% eso es bien importante
vale que vamos a ver el día de hoy bueno
que tenemos que hacer para participar el
campeonato
crear una cuenta de cada academy en este
no nos vamos a detener mucho porque
ustedes ya la saben no sé ya tienen una
cuenta de can agregada días alumnos a su
clase asignar contenido y esta es una
parte súper importante existe un tablero
de control conforme ustedes vayan
avanzando y sus alumnos vayan
contestando las actividades ustedes van
a ir desbloqueando niveles digamos
entonces hay un tablero de control que
existe y en donde ustedes pueden ir
viendo su avance
y formas de cómo usar el campeonato con
sus alumnos o sea formas de motivarlos
bien importante también es que pueden
ser acreedores a un kit y está aquí
también sirve para que ustedes continúen
motivando a sus alumnos y al final vamos
a tener un mínimo espacio de preguntas y
respuestas vale entonces bueno la
primera parte es que tienes que hacer
para participar en el campeonato bueno a
las inscripciones se abrieron desde el
13 de agosto
no importa si ya comenzó como les decía
de todas formas podemos integrarnos no
no pasa nada si si vamos una semana
después o dos semanas después
donde bueno es para cualquier estudiante
de la republica mexicana de primaria a
bachillerato a quien no está limitado
por nivel entonces si yo doy clases de
matemáticas de biología de física en
secundaria y prepa pudo participar en
ambos niveles o solamente en secundaria
solamente en prepa como quieran pero que
por lo menos tengamos una clase eso es
bien importante tiempo para participar
en el campeonato este está pensado para
motivar a los estudiantes sin importar
su nivel
el programa se adapta fácilmente a todo
tipo de aula horario o ambiente escolar
entonces todos nosotros que somos profes
que damos clases de primaria
bachillerato en cualquier ciencia o en
biología física química incluso también
hay temas por ahí de computación de
finanzas podemos participar
cómo puedo participar como profe bueno
obviamente tengo que agregar mis clases
en khan academy y revisar el contenido
que tengo que queremos asignar
acuérdense que dentro del can academy
nosotros tenemos un temario super amplio
entonces dependiendo de ese temario y de
esa materia yo puedo
y asignar qué actividades o qué temas
quiero trabajar con mis alumnos
independientemente de que ellos también
pueden revisar material por su cuenta
obviamente yo soy el profe y yo soy
quien decide que en materia o qué
material perdón es idóneo para trabajar
con mi grupo después los profesores usan
estas herramientas para asignar las
actividades y que haya una práctica
personalizada finalmente como profe
vamos a recibir los datos sobre cada
estudiante y su progreso esto a mí me
sirve como una radiografía de qué están
haciendo los alumnos como los puedo
apoyar en que van a lo mejor un poquito
más bajos cómo podemos rescatar a lo
mejor algún tema que fue un poco más
complicado dentro de la clase y a lo
mejor reforzarlo con actividades a la
par dentro de cada academia que hacen
los alumnos los alumnos tienen
obviamente que completar los ejercicios
a su propio ritmo ok
y realizar las actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento para ganar puntos esto es
bien importante porque hay profesores
que si están participando en el
campeonato ya asignan a lo mejor
contenido de física o de matemáticas que
su materia pero no están no están
asignando contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento y mentalidad de crecimiento
nos da como puntos adicionales un
poquito más adelante vamos a tocar este
punto sale la clase entera podrá ver su
progreso a través de un tablero que va a
marcador los momentos clave y las metas
alcanzadas si yo marqué que este
contenido lo tienen que terminar no sé
antes del viernes porque el viernes es
la fecha límite entonces para que
nosotros podamos ir juntando puntos y
podamos ir avanzando necesitamos que los
alumnos completen las actividades al
100% todos
la que hace se deber a la clase celebra
el descargar los premios una vez que
alcanzan las metas sale acuérdense que
van desbloqueando a niveles entonces
tienen sus bases digitales y cada vez
que ellos van logrando un nivel o
determinado nivel bueno van teniendo
este motivación sale las escuelas que
alcancen más metas van a recibir un
paquete sorpresa de khan academy y esto
es súper interesante ahora como crea una
cuenta y configuró mi clase cuando aquí
está la liga es punto khan academy punto
org
lo voy a salir un momentito
y voy a entrar acá ya como profesor
si yo me vengo aquí a la página de
inicio
ustedes que ya tienen una clase o que ya
tienen una cuenta
esta es su página de inicio entonces
dentro de la página de inicio ustedes
van agregando clases o creando clases
sale entonces aquí por ejemplo yo ya
tengo tres materias hechas o tres clases
hechas
si quisiera hacer una más
podría hacerlo aquí biología por ejemplo
el primero que se me ocurre ya tengo ahí
hecha una ideología que contenido quiero
trabajar con mis alumnos puedo que
trabajar
y este contenido que está aquí de
biología o de alguna otra materia y en
esta parte de aquí abajo viene lo de
mentalidad de crecimiento entonces le
sugiero que agreguen también el
contenido de mentalidad de crecimiento a
sus clases para que puedan ustedes
asignar más actividades relacionadas con
mentalidad de crecimiento y puedan ir
teniendo más puntos una vez que ya
seleccionamos el contenido puedo
importar clases o puedo enviar
invitaciones por correo electrónico o
también puedo compartirles a mis alumnos
el código de la clase y entonces nada
más ellos tienen que entrar a khan
academy punto org diagonal join y meter
este código de la clase para que ya
puedan pertenecer a mí
a mi clase aquí voy a agregar a un
alumno
y es así de fácil que yo ya creé una
clase y tengo por ahí un alumno entonces
si yo seleccione que la materia es de
biología y que yo quiero tener el
contenido de biología me va a aparecer
aquí ya todo el contenido que tengo de
biología desglosado por ejemplo de
introducción a la biología a lo mejor yo
quisiera empezar con estas actividades
de introductorias ahorita que estamos
empezando el semestre
y entonces yo podría asignar todo el
tema
y entonces tengo aquí dos actividades no
que realmente son seis porque dentro de
estas bueno viene como un poco más
desglosado también
entonces selecciona el contenido le doy
a asignar que es para todos mis
estudiantes le pongo una fecha límite
vamos a suponer hoy es 17 la quiero para
la próxima semana a las 11 59 de la
noche
y asigne esa actividad
tengo que asignar tres actividades a la
semana realmente no es mucho y lo ideal
también es que asigne tres actividades y
puedo yo asignar el contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento para los que
ya tenemos a lo mejor las clases creadas
y ya tenemos a nuestros alumnos pero no
seleccionamos mentalidad de crecimiento
lo podemos agregar adicional digamos si
nos vamos a la configuración de nuestra
clase y me vengo aquí en curso aquí dice
curso biología y mentalidad del
crecimiento en el caso de los que no
tengamos seleccionada mentalidad de
crecimiento solamente va a aparecer la
materia o el contenido que yo ya haya
marcado y aquí abajo habilitó mentalidad
de crecimiento y entonces ya tengo la
opción de agregar
es el contenido salen
no sé si hasta aquí haya dudas quitó el
título han sacado el chat
creo que no
ok esa fue la como la primera como un
demo
no sé si hasta aquí déjenme checar el
saquito si hay dudas
por ahí dice no voy a regresar un
poquito
si tengo alumnos que no realizaron las
actividades de la semana pasada todavía
las pueden realizar sí hasta donde tengo
entendido si si se pueden realizar
explicarán el tema de las actividades de
crecimiento como dosificó las
actividades de crecimiento
jose todos y fica las como tú lo
considere pertinente realmente no
tendrías que cumplir como con un mínimo
de las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento si tú vas checando el
el temario me voy a regresar acá
por ejemplo estoy en biología
adiós
aquí esta mentalidad de crecimiento aquí
por ejemplo tengo la introducción del
contenido de mentalidad de crecimiento
cómo implementar la mentalidad de
crecimiento en tu clase la visión
general del plan de estudios para
primaria y secundaria aquí viene por
ejemplo actividades de primaria y
secundaria no sé en qué nivel de esto
josé pero esto es bien importante que lo
podamos abordar con los alumnos porque
trata mucho de
es todo esfuerzo tiene una recompensa
entonces es importante que abordemos con
los alumnos la parte de cómo funciona el
cerebro y
que a todo esfuerzo que yo haga
eventualmente voy a tener un resultado
entonces también es como muy motivante
para ellos que pueden hacer estas
actividades porque los van guiando en un
camino de aprendizaje de vaya manejo de
sus emociones control de sus emociones
aquí por ejemplo la verdad acerca de tu
cerebro mentalidad de crecimiento
errores como piensas un rompecabezas o
sea no importa que yo me equivoque si yo
me equivoco de todas formas voy a
aprender algo y a partir de mi error
yo voy a poder continuar hacia adelante
entonces verás dosificando o vayan las
dosificando como ustedes lo consideren
pertinente yo no sugeriría a lo mejor
que trabajáramos por lo menos una
actividad de mentalidad de crecimiento a
la semana que es tomando en cuenta que
si tenemos que asignar tres bueno con
que asignemos una de ellas me parece
bastante lograble no
un bachillerato josé ok
hay una si no me equivoco christine hay
una liga con contenido para bachillerato
qué ibas a compartir no sé
christina si no se dice son estudiantes
de bachillerato con rezago académico
puedo elegir las de secundaria sí claro
no hay ningún problema jose no hay
ningún problema
cómo se califican las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento tú vas a
obtener
maria de la luz tu vas a obtener los
puntos conforme los alumnos vayan
resolviendo las actividades o sea se
califican igual que como las actividades
de cualquier otra materia digamos o sea
si tienen ya un puntaje establecido y
entonces así es como van ellos a ir lo
vayan desbloqueando logros
ahí están nos está compartiendo por ahí
christina
la liga para bachillerato
para que puedan tener acceso a ese
contenido salen porque había una duda un
poco más atrás tú tú tú tú tú tú tú
por qué no
ok
vale entonces
continuamos
hay una página de soporte técnico de
khan academy en español entonces en esta
misma presentación que estoy utilizando
que es la que la que les va a compartir
hoy ya les compartió christine por ahí
la liga en el chat van ustedes a poder
encontrar las preguntas y respuestas más
comunes hechas en khan academy sale y
recibir el apoyo que necesitan
ahora aquí hay categorías por ejemplo
errores y resolución de problemas las
preguntas frecuentes y preguntas a la
comunidad bueno a lo mejor yo quiero
tratar un tema como muy específico o
saber cómo puedo abordar algo muy
específico con mis alumnos pues hay toda
una comunidad que nos respalda y nos
puede ayudar
a mejorar nuestro desempeño oa llevar
nuestras clases y el uso de khan academy
con nuestro grupo de una mejor manera no
un poco más amigable
ahora bien no sé si haya todavía por ahí
más dudas ahí está la página de soporte
que ya compartió que ya compartió
christine ahora yo les hablaba de un
tablero de control
este tablero de control una vez que
nosotros asignamos el contenido y los
chicos van contestando yo tengo acceso a
este tablero de control que me va
diciendo en qué nivel estamos
como grupo sale algo importante es que
no competimos con otros colegios o con
otros planteles incluso no compartimos
realmente con nadie del colegio o sea si
no lo queremos o sea podemos tener una
competencia amistosa entre grupos entre
la y el b por ejemplo pero de manera
real están compitiendo los alumnos con
ellos mismos entonces es bien importante
que esto quede claro no estoy
compitiendo con ningún plantel estoy
compitiendo contra mí mismo en mis
alumnos están compitiendo contra ellos
mismos en el mismo nivel vale esto es
bien importante porque luego nos puede
generar a nosotros como profesores
ansiedad de decir híjole es que como que
mis alumnos no están subiendo el nivel
no están aprendiendo o no están haciendo
las actividades y voy a quedar malo o el
plantel va a quedar mal no ustedes están
compitiendo contra ustedes vale entonces
es bien importante también que deben de
completar 75 tareas que es un promedio
más o menos de tres tareas por
estudiante
para rellenar cada nivel entonces
conforme vayamos avanzando vamos a poder
ir pasando del nivel 0 al 1 al 2 al 3 al
5 ok y te va diciendo bueno cuántos días
que quedan para completar determinado
nivel
saleh
bien no sé si hasta aquí hubo alguna
duda por ahí creo que no
ok vale cómo puedo usar el campeonato
con mis alumnos no sé si por ahí algunos
de ustedes ya esté usando o está
implementando el campeonato
alguien que ya se haya registrado que
haya empezado a dejar actividades
no
nadie nadie
bueno qué puedo hacer yo como para
motivar a mis alumnos a ver por ahí una
pregunta cuando asigna tareas a algunos
de mis alumnos le informan que no las
recibieron observo que sí están
registrados en la clase
si están registrados en la clase luis
riccardo y si les tiene que llegar la
notificación incluso por correo
electrónico o sea les llega el mensaje
por correo de que tienen tareas
pendientes pero también cuando ellos
entran a khan academy dentro de la clase
les aparece que tienen algo que hacer
o
[Música]
o sea teniendo este problema algo que
comentaba christine es que pueden
escribir al soporte para que los apoyen
y revisar si hay algo más con la cuenta
también ahí en la página que les
compartimos está está esta información
perfecto muchas gracias al yen
excelente
ahora por ahí sí ya hay profesores que
están dejando actividades del campeonato
mago de la luz victoria adolfo antonio
perfecto
[Música]
perfecto qué bueno que ustedes ya están
participando recuerden que tienen que
tener un mínimo de 10 alumnos para ser
considerados dentro del campeonato si
por ahí a alguien le falta un alumno de
los alumnos
agreguen más por favor porque tenemos
necesitamos un mínimo de 10 sale
entonces como los pudo motivar bueno
yo puedo lo mejor como profesor quedar
con ellos de hacer una ceremonia cada
lunes en donde reconozco el esfuerzo de
cada uno de mis alumnos
es bien importante que ellos sientan que
están aprendiendo por supuesto que están
teniendo logros y que el profesor me lo
está reconociendo independientemente de
la plataforma el profesor está
reconociendo que yo estoy teniendo un
avance académico entonces podemos
hacerlo por salón o por grado a veces
hasta en los honores a la bandera de las
escuelas pueden hacer algún
reconocimiento pueden y ustedes también
trabajando por equipos oa lo mejor de
las actividades que vayan dejando pueden
trabajar retos o por retos con los
alumnos entonces quien vaya ganando más
más puntos oa lo mejor podemos designar
un jefe de un equipo vaya nosotros como
profesor generalmente tenemos varias
maneras en donde sabemos dependiendo del
grupo en donde estemos trabajando que
les va a gustar y por donde los puedo
llevar entonces es súper importante que
ustedes motiven a sus alumnos a que
entren a khan academy a que resuelvan
las actividades del campeonato porque
además de aprender se van a divertir
algo súper importante y que los motiva
eso realmente los motiva
perdón voy a revisar un poquito las
dudas acá en el chat cuando algunos
alumnos se integran posteriormente las
actividades asignadas no las ven se
tendrían que reasignar a él tú decías
que te pasa lo mismo que luis ricardo
cierto en ese caso tendría que
escribir a soporte como bien nos dijo
por ahí al y mi compañera
trinidad si los alumnos están
participando en dos asignaturas
diferentes porque les aparecen las
actividades del campeonato en las dos
asignaturas mezcladas
trinidad esto tampoco es normal porque
tendrán que estar te apareciendo por
ejemplo si tienes matemáticas y biología
las actividades divididas
[Música]
ok si tendría que estar apareciendo las
actividades divididas entonces a lo
mejor también es importante que checara
es la página de soporte y sino que
también escribiera soporte porque no sé
si este problema se esté presentando con
la totalidad de los alumnos o sólo con
algunos
[Música]
trinidad
ok no sé si haya por ahí alguien más que
tenga alguna duda sí no
para todos tus alumnos ok
pues entonces sí sería importante
sacarlo con un soporte
louis cada cuánto tiempo se hacen los
campeonatos pues éste empezó ahorita el
10 de septiembre hasta el 16 de
noviembre probablemente obviamente lo
que resta del año no se vaya a hacer no
sabe hacer otro no sé christine si tú
nos puedes decir si para 2019 tienen se
tiene planeado empezar con otro a lo
mejor en enero o si hasta el siguiente
inicio de clases
robot normalmente tenemos este reto para
a celebrar el año del nuevo año escolar
entonces vamos a tener que esperar un
año pero vamos a tener otras campañas
divertidas y maneras de aprovechar la
caneca de mí en enero entonces am esto
es la respuesta
ok perfecto entonces por el inicio del
ciclo escolar nos tendremos que esperar
un año para poder volver a entrar a otro
campeonato
ok vamos a hablar entonces ahora un
poquito de el kit podemos ganar un kit
si nosotros nos aplicamos nuestros
alumnos se aplican y vamos teniendo
puntajes altos cada academy nos puede
recompensar con un kit de clase que
contienen estos kits estilos del
programa postres de mentalidad de
crecimiento que es lo que yo les decía
reconozcamos que aunque yo me equivoque
siempre voy a tener algún aprendizaje de
sus errores y todo esfuerzo siempre va a
tener una recompensa vale y dentro del
kit también vienen lápices entonces está
súper padre la verdad es que los premios
bueno no son premios pero los kits están
súper padres les van a gustar muchísimo
y son otra manera de reconocer el
trabajo y el esfuerzo de todos nuestros
alumnos
no sé si por ahí alguien tenga otras
dudas
muchas gracias luis adolfo valderas
algunos vídeos no se reproducen podrías
darnos un poquito más información adolfo
de de qué es lo que pasa que no te
reproducen los vídeos
y no sé si por ahí alguien más tenga
alguna otra duda
sobre cómo crear las clases o agregar a
los alumnos asignar el contenido
alguien también más tiene por ahí alguna
duda
la parte de mentalidad de crecimiento
nos quedó clara
o tenemos por ahí alguna duda
al internos podrías contar un poquito
más de mentalidad de crecimiento
cómo asignar contenidos claro antonio
por supuesto
me voy a regresar estoy en mi página
inicial
está un poquito lento mi internet pero
bueno ok
ya estoy aquí en mi página inicial
entonces tengo mis clases vamos a
suponer que yo aquí está en donde tengo
biología en este caso ahorita aparece
que tengo un estudiante recuerden que
necesitamos tener como mínimo 10
saleh entonces estoy dentro de mi clase
de biología sale la primera pestaña que
me aparece es la de contenido
tengo contenido tareas actividad lista y
la configuración de mi clase entonces en
la pestaña de contenido tengo todo el
contenido académico de esa materia que
yo acabo de seleccionar entonces aquí
tengo por ejemplo de mentalidad de
crecimiento tengo las actividades de
primarias secundarias de bachillerato y
de la introducción al contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento
entonces por ejemplo si yo quisiera
asignarles dos actividades
aquí por ejemplo me da la vista previa
de lo que viene dentro de esta actividad
o ven dentro de este contenido y lo
puedo ver puedo ver incluso aquí la
vista previa de lo que contiene
vale
con vídeos y todo
y seleccionó aquí lo que yo quiero
asignar para mis alumnos en este caso
voy a asignar estas y son tres
actividades entonces le doy clic en el
botón superior que dice asignar y bueno
a qué clase lo quiero asignar pues esta
clase de biología 1 o de biología 1 se
pueden ser dos o tres o más clases al
mismo tiempo no pasa nada
para todos los estudiantes
puedo poner una fecha límite en este
caso quiero que es el 27 de septiembre
con una hora en específico en este caso
lo voy a dejar las 11 59 de la noche
pero pudiese ser otra hora y le doy clic
en asignar entonces a mis alumnos les va
a llegar la notificación tanto por
correo electrónico de que tienen
actividades pendientes en khan academy
como cuando entren a khan academy dentro
de la materia van a aparecer la
actividad pendiente que tienen que
llevar a cabo
hasta aquí estamos bien
[Música]
como se activa la opción de asignar
contenidos antonio cuando tú creas la
clase
y determinar el contenido voy a crear
una clase desde cero
como que me interné todo uno me está
dejando pero voy a crear una clase desde
cero
[Música]
en cuanto funcione esto
voy a crear una nueva clase que se llame
química tercero c
aquí en química terceros
es esto
es que está un poquito lento
[Música]
no lo vamos a intentarlo de nuevo
cuando yo creo mi clase
agrego mis alumnos ya sea que les pase
el código o los agregue manualmente por
ejemplo alumnos
aquí dice bueno ya tienes la clase
creada después asignar ejercicios
y necesito añadir cursos o sea materias
digamos entonces vamos a ponerle el
contenido de química y recuerden siempre
el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento
entonces este es digamos el contenido
académico que estoy cargando dentro de
mi clase y automáticamente antonio
cuando yo ya tengo el contenido aquí me
aparece asigna meta de dominio o sea que
yo ponga bueno hasta donde tienen que
llegar o qué tanto tienen que saber
manejar vale y el botón de asignar para
que cuando yo seleccione un contenido
está por ejemplo esta unidad de
reacciones químicas y éste que o metría
tiene 37 actividades adentro si yo
quisiera asignar las 37 lo puedo hacer y
si no únicamente puede ir asignando de
un en uno de dos en dos a lo mejor no sé
este digamos la unidad o el módulo y
dentro tenemos subtemas y cada sub tema
tiene determinadas actividades
entonces yo decido como lo quiero
asignar de cuántos en cuanto si quiero
toda la unidad todo el módulo entero en
este caso quise asignar dos nada más
y entonces le doy clic en asignar para
que el grupo puedo asignarlo para uno o
para varios al mismo tiempo con la fecha
límite que yo quiera
en este caso ahorita por ejemplo no me
deja asignarlo porque todavía no tengo
estudiantes no se me ha alumno todavía
no ha aceptado la invitación y no se ha
agregado a mi clase tales pero puedo
darle clic en guardar y asignar más
tarde o si yo ya tuviera me saturé a
estudiantes en activo le doy clic en
asignar y automáticamente se les manda
la actividad
vale
por ahí teníamos cómo funciona el
tablero
cómo funciona el tablero de control
perla
o
antonio en la clase que creen les asigne
previamente pre álgebra ajá
y no te aparece el botón de asignar a
antonio
por ahí dice a veces al hacer esto me
marcaba que no se podían asignar
y no te dejaba asignar las heces o
eventualmente si podía o sea si se podía
mandar el contenido de tus alumnos
jose ya tengo creadas las clases y los
alumnos registrados en grupo de química
y otro maestro los tiene registrados en
matemáticas solo una adición a las
actividades de crecimiento
pudieron asignar las las 2 los 2 jose
pero poniéndose de acuerdo porque el
contenido es prácticamente pues el mismo
entonces no tendría caso que se asignará
lo mismo en las dos materias
a lo mejor pudieran ponerse de acuerdo y
decir bueno yo dejo un acto dejas otra o
solamente yo este asignó las de
mentalidad de crecimiento está esa
mentalidad de crecimiento nos dan puntos
adicionales
ya siguiente más de préval g bra pero
quiero asignarlo de crecimiento ok
antonio acuérdate que tienes que dar de
alta el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento entonces aquí en
configuración en donde está curso pues
tienes aquí pre álgebra y para que
puedas asignar mentalidad de crecimiento
le damos clic en cambiar curso y
agregamos mentalidad de crecimiento no
sé si ya lo hiciste si ya lo hiciste
entonces aquí en donde tenemos el
contenido si le das clic en química o el
perdón entre álgebra vas a poder cambiar
la mentalidad de crecimiento y entonces
únicamente te va a aparecer aquí el
contenido de
de esa materia digamos
efe eventualmente manera de actividad
fue asignando de una en una o sea no te
dejaba asignar varias al mismo tiempo es
perla
perla del tablero de progreso si
justamente va por niveles como forme tú
vas avanzando un nivel se va éste se va
llenando este y te va marcando un
progreso te faltan
68 días por ejemplo o menos no sé para
completar el nivel 6
y así lo va a seguir viendo tú la idea
es que con este tablero de progreso
tanto ustedes como profesores y los
estudiantes celebren el progreso de la
clase juntos cuando se pone el botoncito
este de celebrar y le das clic y bueno
son estos premios que les llamamos
digitales que son los que también nos
ayudan mucho a motivar a los alumnos
ahorita este lado si me dejas comparte
la pantalla para que vean el ciclo blair
[Música]
y listo gracias
este es el tablero y bueno es ahorita
está imágenes que se muestra está en el
nivel 0 pero bueno si tú cumples los 100
a siemens que aquí tenés pues no ya este
va a ir avanzando y tú vas avanzando en
el en el tablero por niveles puedes
hacer cuantos niveles quieras no estás
así como limitado y bueno este es el
tablero del progreso como te decía aquí
te dice cuántos días que faltan para
completar el nivel 6 te pide te motiva a
que continúe avanzando que continúes
este
trabajando ahorita va a entrar acá
no sé si con eso este responde tu
pregunta mira aquí te va dando tú
tu progreso ahí ya viste cómo lo va
marcando
y te va diciendo en qué nivel van se va
llenando una barrita y el porcentaje
y cada que avancen a un nivel pues vas a
ir llenando este este tablero
vale
por favor ahorita si puedes decirme si
conteste tu pregunta y si no pues ya
vemos
y complete este nivel y bueno mis
sorpresas de celebración no
o sea se hace como la musiquita el
confeti y eso anima bastante a los
chicos
muchas gracias salen de acá en el chat
perla gracias
donde puedo obtener el tablero o yo lo
puedo hacer no antonio viene dentro de
cada ccaa de mí
a ver alguien estaba por ahí
compartiendo su pantalla si no la
comparte
cuando tú te inscribes en el campeonato
antonio ya que tienes clases con mínimo
10 alumnos y ojo esto es bien importante
tenemos que eliminar todas las clases
que ya no estemos utilizando todas las
clases pasadas
es importante que las eliminemos
como para que no nos estorben porque se
toman en cuenta las clases que tengamos
activas
entonces y por ahí tenemos una clase en
el campeonato que no se llevaba yo el
año pasado o algo así ya no está activa
eliminemos la
voy a regresar un poquito aquí en
configuración en eliminar esta clase si
es una clase que ya no está activa pues
entonces eliminen la ahora
si yo ya estoy registrado en el
campeonato
voy a tener acceso al tablero de control
por cada una de mis clases en esta clase
por ejemplo estas clases mías tienen un
estudiante tienen pocos estudiantes pero
dentro de cada una de estas clases si
tengo más de 10 estudiantes yo tengo
acceso al tablero de control
entonces no es algo que creas tú es algo
que vaya ya está por default cuando tú
estás participando en el campeonato
me voy a regresar un poco a las dudas
alguien por ahí tenía una duda que no
leí
mírame el kit
como entrega en el kit
christina que cuando se va a enterrar el
kit hacia el final del campeonato
todos estos en vez no van a blog porque
hay un límite pero vamos a tener algunas
oportunidades en las próximas semanas
donde pueden ganar un un que pero
también van a recibir los correos y
estas oportunidades a través de estos
webinars pero también a través de
correos electrónicos por esto es muy
importante que están escribiendo se en
el campeonato
exactamente no es para todos el kit pero
dependiendo del desempeño
pueden ser acreedores a este kit para
que continúen motivando a sus
estudiantes
de antonio porque dice ya borre otras
clases y ahora tengo 21 estudiantes está
perfecto está perfecto antonio con 21
estudiantes puedes trabajar
perfectamente bien
alguien más tiene por ahí alguna duda
qué pasa dice a ver qué pasa si se
termina el nivel 6 antes de tiempo y las
actividades de crecimiento cuentan para
el campeonato si jose las actividades de
de mentalidad de crecimiento cuentan por
supuesto te dan como puntos adicionales
y otra vez me regreso con david qué pasa
si se termine el nivel 6 antes de tiempo
nada o sea por nosotros mejor si tú
cumples con las actividades o con los
niveles
antes de tiempo quiere decir que el
rendimiento de tus alumnos está subiendo
y
ninguna otra duda por ahí elena
y entonces ustedes vayan desbloqueando
digamos los niveles
mejorando el desempeño y el rendimiento
académico está excelente
alguien más tiene alguna otra duda
aunque bueno que me han estado
reportando mis alumnos que no les
permite avanzar en sus actividades elena
nos podrías dar más información de eso o
se les aparece algún mensaje de error
no pueden completarlas por equis razón
hay muchas gracias.antonio muchas muchas
gracias pues es un esfuerzo que que hace
todo el equipo de khan academy por
darles a ustedes contenido de calidad y
que les solucione un poquito la vida
trabajando con sus alumnos
muchas gracias
alguien más tiene por ahí alguna duda
no les registran sus avances en el
material que les compartimos hace un
momentito que es esta presentación que
yo estuve utilizando viene a la liga de
soporte alomejor elena valdría la pena
que pudieras escribir el equipo de
soporte comentándoles esto para saber de
qué manera te podemos apoyar e incluso
si pudieras tener alguna captura de
pantalla de algún alumno que no le
aparezca el error o que no le deje
avanzar en las actividades nos puede
servir a nosotros para saber cuál está
haciendo el problema
me informa que está dando respuestas
[Música]
ok si elena te agradeceríamos mucho si
nos haces llegar esta información al
soporte para saber de qué manera los
podemos apoyar
muchas gracias.antonio
cuando sentimos el soporte este la puso
cristina al principio ya lo intenté
copiar pero no me deja porque me dice
que es una página web pero si la buscas
elena hasta arriba viene la liga y dice
ahí que es la página de soporte al darle
clic te lleva directo y si no igual y
exacto a christina nos puede ayudar a
copiarla nuevamente por favor
ahí está ya nos hizo cristian el enorme
favor de ponerla por ahí
para que puedas acceder algo muy
importante es que caneca de mí méxico
está buscando a docentes del conalep y
también otros sistemas que están
teniendo éxito con el reto porque
queremos entrevistar a ustedes y también
crear vídeos y cosas así entonces
por favor queremos saber lo que está
pasando con el reto con sus alumnos y
los el éxito que están teniendo
y puedan compartir eso a través de
twitter pero también a través de o la
arroba khan academy punto o hereje
exacto aquí voy a poner que youtube
aquí les voy a poner
el hashtag
que les pedimos que utilicen para que
compartan las experiencias con nosotros
sus fotos videos a lo mejor cuando
celebran los logros con sus alumnos
eso es padrísimo de ver entonces si las
comparten en redes sociales por favor
usen el hashtag campeonato para que
nosotros podamos ver qué es lo que está
pasando en sus aulas cómo están
llevándolo a cabo si les gusta si los
motiva eso para nosotros también es
súper enriquecedor
vale
no sé si haya por ahí en el chat alguna
otra duda un comentario y hay
constancias de participación en estos
cursos de khan academy y si maria de la
luz
si te registraste en el formulario
inicial
se te da el reconocimiento de estas
horas de capacitación
también por ahí en la presentación
inicial que nos compartió christine que
les puso ahí la liga en el chat ustedes
entran a ese formulario se registran
este con el correo con el que ustedes
están registrados en cada academy para
poder tener la constancia
muchas gracias selena sí sí nos pudieras
hacer llegar esas capturas a soporte que
lo agradeceríamos mucho para saber de
qué manera ayudarles
alguien más algo tú christine algo más
no pero muchísimas gracias por venir sé
que ustedes tienen mucho trabajo al
principio de el año escolar
y pues estamos en contacto y muchísimas
gracias por venir vamos a crear otras
opciones a mamás capacitaciones y más
web henares
en las próximas semanas entonces nos
vemos pronto gracias muchísimas gracias